and now dear friends it is time for
tonight's motivational hashtag some of
your every gossip website is filled with
already skinny celebrities talking about
how they just want to lose enough weight
to fit safely inside the overhead bin
you know what I mean
to show our support for their struggle
this year tonight's hashtag is healthier
celebs examples might be Morgan gluten
Freeman and Jack Black underfoot 60
seconds and begin
marcella flax alloys whites a fee on
kale Earnhardt jr. points Marcella
vitamin C low points Amanda meek
treadmill points Marcella
Sarah Jessica Parker boys Brad Pitt yep
points I saw Denzel Washington
Megan personal trainer yes points
very good Marcela or again Nicki Minaj
yes Chris Rock harder commander Liu pita
bread Nyong'o yes points
Burnie macrobiotic boys Amanda tofu
grace yes points
very good atheon Drake wait
Amanda the artist formerly known as
spring yes